das thema über das wir heute reden kann
einem richtig angst einjagen was wenn
ich mal zu jenen gehören sollte bei
denen demenz aus bricht die krankheit
die nach und nach jede erinnerung löscht
bin ich dann noch ich was würde ich
empfinden wenn ich nichts mehr denken
kann aus dem land des vergessens kommt
keiner zurück der es uns erzählen könnte
doch unser gesprächsgast michael
schmieder erlebt seit 30 jahren ganz nah
mit demenzkranken zusammen und gilt als
pionier den der pflege dieser menschen
vieles eigentlich fast alles geändert
und mit dem zürcher heim sonnweid eine
der weltweit besten betreuungsstätten
für demenzkranke geschaffen hat ein
kämpfer für die würde dieser sehr
verletzlichen menschen ist er zudem
herr schmiede willkommen wie möchten sie
einst lieber sterben plötzlicher herztod
und in einer sekunde weg oder nach
langer liebevoller pflege in ihrem heim
wie dem ihren der herztod ist keine
alternative
aber liebevoll gepflegt werden das wäre
einer und ich würde vorziehen immer
vorziehen noch abschied nehmen können
ob ich das noch realisieren oder nicht
spielt keine rolle
aber ich will zeit haben für diese jetzt
für diesen letzten abschnitt hat die
tatsache dass sie 30 jahre schon an
einer städte arbeiten wo die menschen
zum schluss sterben gehen
ihr verhältnis zum tod verändern
ich hatte immer eine sehr enge beziehung
zum sterben ich habe sehr früh meinen
vater verloren habe einen bruder
verloren und ich war als katholischer
ministrant bei vielen vielen
beerdigungen dabei und irgendwie habe
ich immer eine nähe zum tod gehabt
ich glaube es hat meine einstellung dazu
geändert dass ich mehr merkel menschen
mit demenz auch ohne demenz hoffentlich
können friedlich sterben und das was ich
auch weiß ist dass diese filmreifen
letzten worte in der regel nicht
stattfinden man kann sagen
sie sind eingestiegen in die
demenzbetreuung ein bisschen mit der
parole vergesst alle pflege dogmas das
schmiede konzept ist eigentlich so dass
sie alles anders machen und das
beschreiben sie auch im buch neuen buch
demenz aber nicht bescheuert und das
erste was mich erstaunt hat bei der
lektüre des buches ist wenn die menschen
kommen die angehörigen ihren liebsten
ihre liebste bringen für diesen ersten
schritt auf dem langen weg des abschieds
das weiß man die menschen kommen habe
ich nicht zurück dann findet das
erstgespräch ohne den patienten statt
das hat mich sehr überrascht
das ist das ergebnis von erfahrungen
dass man wenn man dieses erstgespräch ab
macht dann ist da zuhause immer etwas
passiert es kann nicht sein dass jemand
einfach anruft wir gehen jetzt ein
erstgespräch führen das heißt wir haben
eine situation in der wir schauen müssen
dass der mensch der diese erkrankung
erkrankung hat dass er nicht dabei ist
weil es geht um ihn und vermutlich kann
er das was gesprochen wird gar nicht
erfassen in seiner ganzen dimension wir
wissen heute dass menschen mit demenz
ungefähr noch die hälfte verstehen von
dem was wir reden und dann finde ich das
gemein dass man über jemand redet er am
tisch sitzt und gar nicht weiß um was es
geht aber spürt dass es um ihn geht und
dass es eine schwere hat in diesem
gespräch
und das wollten wir eliminieren und das
haben wir eliminiert und das machen wir
sehr konsequent
man stellt sich schnell vor das muss ein
ungeheuer hart im moment seien nicht nur
für den patienten für die angehörigen da
ist wenn die leute kommen zu mir das
gespräch und der patient dann bleibt
vielleicht etwas ganz einschneiden das
im leben dieser menschen passiert man
muss sich das so vorstellen man gibt ja
niemand gerne weg hoffentlich
aber es ist doch dann diese ohnmacht in
der man drin ist und spürt es geht zu
hause nicht mehr
man ist überfordert es sind geschehen ja
so viele dinge zu hause die wir gar
nicht nachvollziehen können wenn wir uns
nur vorstellen jemand steht achtmal in
der nacht auf die ehefrau ist selbst
schon 80 wie soll sie das überleben und
der vater der kranker mann will jetzt
lieber noch arbeiten nachts um 2 also
das sind gewaltige schritte und das
macht man nicht freiwillig und das ist
tatsächlich ein ganz schwieriger moment
für die angehörigen die jemand bringen
müssen
sie beschreiben auch eindrücklich die
tatsache dass am abend vor dem tag wo
der patient eintritt der menschen ryzom
ein ehepartner ist das letzte mal dass
wir nebeneinander schlafen
reden sie dann in diesem erstgespräch
über über diese existenziellen
herausforderungen
das ist das ziel dieses erstgespräch ist
dass man überhaupt einmal die situation
erfasst und dass man den dem gesunden
das gefühl geben kann
das was er geleistet hat bis jetzt was
das unglaubliche leistung ist und dass
man da wir da sind um das zu
unterstützen dass das einfacher wird in
zukunft also das versuchen wir dort zu
machen damit der kran der gesunde dass
der abschied einfacher fällt gibt es
patienten die an zögern und wenn sie mal
dort sind und warten vor dem zimmer wo
sie das gespräch haben mit dem namen
ändern sagen ich möchte doch nicht
bleiben also man muss sich das so
vorstellen das erstgespräch findet zwei
drei monate vor dem eintritt tag statt
aber es gibt schon leute die kommen wenn
dann der eintritt stargästen sorgen hier
bleibe ich nicht da haben wir immer
wieder beispiele und da ist es dann ganz
wichtig dass man das die menschen
emotional ankommen können
man kann noch so ein schönes zimmer
haben aber wenn serien losigkeit
empfängt dann will man dort nicht sein
dass grund
prinzip dieser arbeit die wir tun heißt
den menschen die möglichkeit gegeben
dass er an kommen kann dass er innerlich
ankommen kann und das ist das was unsere
pflegenden auch was für schulen und was
sie auch machen und was er auch
hervorragend machen wenn man ihr heim
sieht sie haben mich vor ein paar tagen
eingeladen einen nachmittag dort zu
verbringen sieht man ist man vielleicht
sogar erstand das ist sehr schön ist
gewisse räume sehen eigentlich aus wie
in einem hotel fast ein wellness zimmer
könnte man sagen ist dass das konzept
dass hier die leute sicher so was die
einem hotel wohl fühlen sollen
ich glaube schöne räume schöne umgebung
hat eine auswirkung auf den menschen auf
sein seelenleben
und wir haben die erfahrung gemacht dass
die welt wenn der sich schön machen dass
sie dann auch schön wahrgenommen wird
also die idee vom wellnesshotel als
nicht als konzept aber so die art von
wohnen das ist schon das haben wir hier
versucht die die leute da sieht man auch
wenn man besucht werden liebevoll
gepflegt gibt in haus quasi zum beispiel
das sieht alles sehr edel aus bedeutet
es dass es ein luxus heim ist wohl nur
sehr reiche leute kommen kann werde ich
immer gefragt es ist nicht das ist kein
luxus sein
bei uns können menschenleben die kein
geld haben die von ergänzungsleistungen
abhängig sind die können bei uns genauso
leben
die preise sind in dem rahmen von
normaler alter menschen die pflege
brauchen wenn der patient zögert wie sie
die vorher gesagt haben dass das
durchaus vorkommen kann muss er
unterschreiben nicht bleibe für immer
oder kann er sagen okay ich komme auf
probe bei uns muss niemand
unterschreiben weil es keine
es gibt kein recht für jemanden der
einzufordern der das nicht versteht was
wir versuchen manchmal dass wir menschen
in ferien nehmen und sie dann
anschließend entscheiden können ob sie
bleiben
das geht aber nur in einer bestimmten
phase der erkrankung
ansonsten ist er da und er ist
eindeutig da und dann ist es unsere
aufgabe alles zu tun dafür dass man
ankommen kann und das kann auch heißen
dass man wirklich den ersten abend auf
der schwierig ist dass man da 121
betreuen muss dass man ganz nah bei ihm
sein muss das erste mal hier schlafen
das ist man für viele doch noch
schwierig gleichzeitig ist die andere
geschichte
wenn ich irgendwo ankommen und die
menschen sind mir wohlgesonnen dann bin
ich da und das ist das was wir natürlich
versuchen werden es auch für die seele
hier kannst du seien hier in stressen
wir dich das ist ja das motto dass wir
mit möglichst wenig stress arbeiten für
diese menschen und wenn stress wegfällt
das merken menschen sofort ohne jeden
zynismus wage ich zu fragen gibt es dann
menschen patienten die schnell schon am
nächsten tag vergessen woher sie kommen
und nicht mehr umtrieben werden durch
den verlust oder dauert das immer seine
zeit
nein es gibt ganz viele menschen die
sind da wenn sie da sind
das ist ja dieses phänomen an dieser
erkrankung menschen mit demenz leben
immer nur im jetzt das jetzt ist jetzt
das kann aber sein dass sie in der
vorstellung der mensch vielleicht 20
jahre zurück lebt aber ist es trotzdem
jetzt und der mensch passt sich an das
was jetzt ist also wir haben weniger
menschen die hadern mit dem eintritt
werden viel mehr menschen die kommen
sind angekommen und sind da und das ist
das faszinierende natürlich auch an
dieser krankheit auf das fast eine
sonnenseite einer sehr düsteren
krankheit sein kann will ich sie dann
noch fragen carpe diem könnte man sagen
es gilt dass sie dir gleich uns man soll
jetzt leben und die gegenwart beim
schopf packen
aber der mensch ist ja eine krankheit
die auch ganz andere philosophische
fragen aufwirft fragen die die
philosophie seit jahrtausenden
mit sich herumträgt quasi die frage was
ist ein mensch und bei ihnen ist die
frage was ist ein mensch ohne erinnerung
was bin ich wenn dass ich weg ist was
ich die erfahrung wie lange tragen die
menschen ihr ich ihr bisherige sich noch
mit dass ich direkt man mit bis zum tod
sie haben jetzt gesagt das bisherige ich
wir müssen zu gestehen dass den menschen
das das ich sich verändert dass wir das
ich nicht mehr erkennen von außen aber
dass ich bringt jeder mensch mit und er
geht mit diesem ich von dieser welt und
es gibt ja dann auch das zeigt sich
häufig auch in ganz kleinigkeiten dass
man sagt ja da ist die person noch mal
wie man sie vielleicht kennen gelernt
hat aber es kann auch sein dass das
nicht ist aber manchmal flackert es
wieder auf das frühere ich vielleicht
etwas wie ich gar nicht erkennen und das
nutzen sie auf werde fast schon sagen
charmante weise es gibt dem buch die
geschichte von einem herrn banking
sichern dass das alles pseudonyme sind
aber hier der herr gerking der war in
früheren jahren oberst im generalstab
und damit machen sie etwas ja damit
machen wir etwas aber nur in dem moment
wenn er sich in dieser situation fühlt
wir sagen nicht herr gerken sie waren ja
oberst im generalstab sondern wenn er
hat ja diese karte kühlen angeschaut hat
die rausgenommen aus dem aus der box und
hat geschaut dass wir die dokumentation
sollen patienten patienten dokumentation
als aus damit dem betreuer nimm dir aus
und schaut die augen und sagt dann
irgendwann alle simulanten der gleiche
her hat übrigens auch etwas
faszinierendes gemacht er war oberst im
generalstab im zweiten weltkrieg also
der mann war ja oben an der leiter und
irgendwann hat er sich bitter beschwert
dass er es nur zum läuten gebracht hat
in seinem leben
er hat tatsächlich die erfüllung von
seinem berufsleben von seinen zielen
selbst das hat er vergessen mich hat das
sehr erschrocken dass man also selbst
wenn man ein zufriedenes leben hat das
hat ja mit zufriedenheit nichts zu tun
aber wenn man die ziele erfüllt hat wenn
man das vergessen hat dann hat er dort
mal nach außen durch auch seinen wert
verloren
und das gibt eine relation zu unserer
tätigkeit wir halten uns ja für immens
wichtig was wird da sitzen und so wir
haben ja eine botschaft aber wenn wir
das alles nachher vergessen was bleibt
dann noch ist ihre erfahrung dass es die
meisten ganz vergessen oder spüren sie
bei vielen menschen auch noch gibt die
geschichte von frau mühlegg die war eine
patrizier ihn quasi große will am
zürichsee
viele bedienstete bleibt bei gewissen
menschen der habitus ich bin wichtig ich
habe bedienstete bleibt dr
der habitus bleibt manchmal und dann
versuchen wir auch die menschen dort
abzuholen wo sie diesen habitus zeiten
das kann man das geld gut also wir
versuchen ja jeder mensch bringt ja was
mit ob das der der maurer ist oder egal
wer
jeder bringt etwas mit und das versuchen
wir mit ihm zusammen zu kultivieren zu
erhalten so wie er sein leben gestaltet
hat oder wie sie jetzt auch lebt das
wollen wir mit ihm weiter führen
am beispiel von oberst gerking habe ich
etwas anderes noch überraschend gefunden
es gibt eine szene an die situation die
wirklich wahr wo man ihnen dazu bringen
will
glaube ich einen anderen patienten nicht
mehr dauernd nachzulaufen und während
woanders hinzugehen und dann nutzt man
sein ehemaliges
offizier sein das ist das fand ich ganz
gleichzeitig charmant und ich habe dann
eine kritische frage dazu er hat sich ja
dann beschwert das biete über diesen
mann und war dann ziemlich aufgebracht
und dann hat eine pflegedienstleiterin
bei uns hat dann sehr militärisch
reagiert und das hat er dann akzeptiert
und dann hat sie gemeldet dass die
rabatten im garreler überprüft werden
müssen und sie gut ausgelegt sind
rechner sind und das hat er gerne dann
überprüft und ist damit da geht es ja
nur darum dass man ihm das bestätigt ja
er selber hat ja gar nichts mehr gemacht
ja im buch wenn ich richtig gelesen aber
geht er dann in den garten wir haben
auch diesen garten als bild hier weil es
wirklich sehr schön anzuschauen
der garten hat in ihrem heim und für das
einmal eine große bedeutung habe sie
müssen sich vorstellen menschen mit
demenz wissen nicht dass sie dement sind
das ist mal eine also machen wir auch
nicht einen demenzgarten firmen wir
machen ein garten für menschen und im
garten müssen sich alle menschen wohl
fühlen und nicht diagnose abhängig
irgend jemand der die diagnose fühlt
sich wohl die anderen nicht und nach
draußen können sich bewegen können war
nicht will
das ist ein für mich ein grundrecht des
menschen haben unabhängig von ihrer
krankheit
es nützt ihnen nichts wenn draußen die
sonne scheint jemand will raus und die
türe ist verschlossen
das darf man nicht tun sondern wir
müssen den menschen diesen garten
zugänglich machen und das sind die
elemente da ist das wasser da ist die
wir arbeiten ja sehr stark mit diesen
elementen
wer bin ich wenn mein bisheriges ich weg
ist so lautet die frage
philosophisch praktisch lautet sie auch
müssen sie und wollen sie wissen
ziemlich genau wissen wer der mensch war
der jetzt bei ihnen als patient ist wohl
wissen sie es wollen sie es ist wir
wollen wissen vielleicht wie hat er
gelebt was hat er in seiner gearbeitet
wie es die familiensituation
wir wollen primär nicht wissen über hat
er dunkle stellen oder hat er keine und
wir wollen über diese dunkle stellen
auch primär nichts wissen es ist nicht
unsere aufgabe irgendwelche knackpunkte
im leben zu analysieren überhaupt die
rauszubringen
der mensch ist mehr als das und
eindrücklich war ja dass bei einem mann
der war sehr freundlich zu den
mitarbeitenden aber sehr liebevoll unser
gestorben war kam ein brief von freunden
nur geschrieben haben er hatte es als
schwierig mit seiner pädophilie wenn ich
so was er weiß und das steht dann in
diesem car tax in dieser dokumentation
sondern eigentlich schon mal jeder
zugang der auf dieser station arbeitet
und dann heißt das sofort der pädophile
und ich glaube um den menschen zu
akzeptieren als person als mensch muss
ich das nicht wissen weil es bekommt
sonst ein zu großes gewicht
ich muss nicht wissen ob jemand
abgetrieben hat im leben ich muss nicht
wissen ob jemand andere gequält hat in
dem moment wenn er bei uns ist ist er in
einer anderen situation in einem anderen
jetzt würde das auch heißen aus ihrer
sicht ist der ein anderer also diese
idee von der person die eine kohärente
zusammenhängende lebensgeschichte hat
die kommt ja dann den siebzehnten
jahrhundert in die philosophiegeschichte
john lockt der große liberale philosoph
der engländer
da sagt der mensch ist eigentlich die
summe seiner erinnerungen was er noch
weiß wie er sich sieht wie das
zusammenpassen
sagen sie jetzt wenn die erinnerung dann
weg ist ist man halt ein anderer oder
glauben sie an den kern oder eine seele
vielleicht sogar ich glaube an die seele
ja dann im kern
ich glaube es ist der gleiche mann
gewesen aber das prädikat pädophil
ja das war zu diesem zeitpunkt bei uns
nicht mehr relevant und dann muss ich
das auch nicht nur damit wir zufrieden
sind mit dieser information dann muss
ich das auch nicht heraus
wir haben manchmal situationen wo wir
sagen könnte es etwas gegeben haben in
der lebensgeschichte von einer person
was uns jetzt helfen würde und dann
versuchen wir mit der angehörigen das zu
besprechen wenn eine idee da ist heißt
das noch lange nicht dass das die
ursache ist
wir wollen ja alles immer begründen
warum ist herr meier so wir wollen
versuchen grund für das und das liefern
uns diese menschen nicht mehr und wir
lernen zu akzeptieren es ist jetzt so es
ist wie es ist gibt es irgendeinen
einspruch locker sagt hat man den
radikalen gedanken geäußert man müsste
immer nach vier jahren jeden
strafgefangenen frei lassen weil
körperlich gesehen jede zelle innerhalb
von vier jahren wecken und er ist
eigentlich mehr der gleiche mensch dass
man dich jetzt auch ziemlich radikal
weil würde ich eher mit schon lockt
sagen er weiß noch was er getan hat die
erinnerung sind aber würden sie sagen
ganz spät wenn dann das denken weg geht
gibt es diese gnade quasi das vergessen
sollte sie geben das glaube ich dass es
das gibt und ich gestehe dass den
menschen auch zu während manchmal sagen
wir ja auch man sollte vergessen können
nur vergessen wir wollen eigentlich das
vergessen was wir nicht behalten wollen
aber ein mensch mit demenz vergisst
einfach alles oder sehr viel und das ist
der unterschied wir wollen entscheiden
was wir vergessen
aber das macht er ja nicht mehr er
vergisst einfach komplett dann erlaube
ich mir noch kurz nach zu bauen was sind
sie eigentlich für ein verschmähter wenn
wir sagen wie war der mensch aber nur
ganz kurz aber ich habe mit interesse so
man ihre biografie studiert gesehen da
gibt es diesen moment sie waren 29 jahre
alt da sie waren pfleger psychatrie
pflege gab gerontologie und dann sagen
sie jetzt übernehme ich ein heim das war
damals die soweit ein heim wo leute
waren sich
das in dieser schroffheit leute die
niemand wollte warum geht ein 29 und
sagt ich will hier ist ein solches heim
übernehmen ich wollte eine verantwortung
eine führungsverantwortung übernehmen
ich habe eigentlich war mir die sparte
egal ich habe ich habe gesucht und das
hat sich auf ganz komischen wegen bin
ich dazu gekommen über eine wanderung
mit einem bekannten hat mir jemand
kennengelernt der da das heim gekannt
hat also ich habe nicht speziell demenz
gesucht aber ich habe sehr rasch dann
festgestellt dass das etwas sehr
faszinierend das hatte sie wollten
verantwortung macht auch macht natürlich
das streite ich nicht ab
sind sie heute noch einer der gern die
rolle dessen hat der entscheidet der die
macht hat
ich glaube macht gebe ich heute lieber
ab aber ich habe schon noch gerne
einfluss vielleicht kann man das so
nennen und macht egal auf welchen ich
über spitze aber sich sagt die branche
haben ja gleich ich hätte auch ein
wellness hotel über 900 das wasser ist
so ein zufall dass ihr berufliches
lebens thema demenz in ihr leben kann ja
das war zufall
aber ich wollte immer in der pflege
bleiben das war nie das thema ich wollte
ich heute noch ich würde die dort den
gleichen beruf lernen dass die der
kontakt die nähe von mitmenschen in
extremsituationen das sind ja kranke
menschen
das hat mich immer fasziniert weil man
viel näher an die menschen kommt wenn
sie krank sind botschaften sind dann
darf man ist weg von allem war es darum
uns ablenkt da geht es immer nur ins
existenzielle das hat mich immer
fasziniert
dann haben sie gewiss entdeckt wie
scharf und schockierende sein kann für
die betreuenden für die angehörigen eben
was da passiert damit sie es ein
bisschen nachspüren können mit medialen
mitteln habe ich einen ausschnitt
mitgebracht aus dem film
vergissmeinnicht der deutsche
filmemacher david sieveking dokumentiert
das entschwinden seiner mutter in die
demenz in einem film oder kameramann
eigentlich dauernd erweisen da gibt es
diese szene wo er die mutter betreut
weil der mann der gesund ist auch in den
ferien ist weg ist und der mann ruft
dann an und diese chance hat wenn ein
angehöriger plötzlich in einer anderen
realität so titel erstmal eins von den
früchten von diesem gelben hier ist mal
so irgendwie weiß nicht so recht weiß
dass ein staat das ist lecker ich weiß
nicht was das sein soll eine aprikose
aber da macht man keine butter drauf
macht man nicht die macht man aufs brot
die manchmal gar nicht später zurück
hast du gut geschlagen ja der malta hat
angerufen der ist gut angekommen in der
schweiz heisst ja alte malte dein mann
ist ja nicht mein mann
naja mein vater bereite malte malta und
warum denn nicht
so fand es auch aber du bist meine
mutter und er ist mein vater und ihr
wohnt hier als mich seit war ich nämlich
schon in dem haus hier habt ihr fast
fast 30 jahre zusammen gewohnt ist ich
kann ich mir nicht die zwar über 20
jahre
das habe ich nie gehört und mit ihm
verheiratet bist du auch schon seit über
40 jahren was dein mann für ein mann
meinte mein vater aber du wirst meine
mutter ich dachte du wärst er war der
vater
neben ich bin david du bist der mutter
ich bin der sohn ich plötzlich so nah
dran mich überhaupt nicht mehr hin
sie haben momentweise geschmunzelt und
dann ist man dann erschaudert mann
er hat 30 jahre zusammengelebt das kann
ich mir nicht vorstellen wäre es richtig
zu sagen vielleicht schlimmer noch als
für die patientin es für den angehörigen
da sieht man deutlich ja und er versucht
eigentlich nur das erbe steinbild
bestätigt bekommt es geht ihm überhaupt
nicht mehr um die informationen von der
mutter er will nur noch bestätigen dass
sie ja sagt du bist mein sohn er für
sicher hält das fast nicht mehr aus dass
die frau das faszinierend zeigt sie hat
vergessen sie hat 40 jahre vergessen
sie lebt in dem moment in einer zeit die
vor ihrer hochzeit war
wie soll sie sich daran erinnern an an
etwas was sie vergessen hat wissen wir
wo sie jetzt lebt also mal sicher vor
der hochzeit ja
und wahrscheinlich hat sie geglaubt er
der sohn ist ihr freund oder ehemann
es gibt tatsächlich die situation und
ich habe von angehörigen von einem sohn
habe ich das so gehört die hatten die
mutter eingeladen zum heiligabend in die
familie
und plötzlich wollte die mutter ins
ehebett liegen und plötzlich wollte die
mutter hat sie geglaubt ihr sohn sei ihr
mann und wollte ihren sohn verführen
das hat eskaliert an diesem abend musste
die mutter in der nacht noch nach hause
fahren
die hat der junge mann der sohn sieht ja
aus irgendwie wie der ehemann und dann
vergisst man dass das der sohn ist und
dann wird er definiert als ehemann und
genau das ist in diesem ein spieler auch
passiert wir sehen das häufig bei
menschen die reden die kosten mit 20
jahren vielleicht in die deutsche
schweiz gekommen haben freie englisch
gesprochen weil sie aus england und im
lauf dieser krankheit die das völlig weg
das verständnis der deutsch- und
plötzlich bedienen diese menschen wieder
englisch zu sprechen
und dann hat man so eine kleine ahnung
wo man sprachlich ungefähr sich bewegt
was muss man tun muss man mit ihnen
gehen und
sagen wir sind wir halt wieder in dieser
zeit aber das wird dann natürlich
belastend und hey kleben wenn es in
beziehungsfragen geht was muss man denn
wir sind nicht in dieser zeit aber wir
können ihn begleiten in dieser zeit er
kann hingehen und sagen ja mal da ist
einmal das hat das hat er getan und dann
hat ja aber da und gesagt ich weiß das
nicht mehr
dann könnte er für sicher nur sagen dann
hat es für sie keine relevanz als er
könnte sein interesse eigentlichen
hintergrund stellen und sagen ja dann
ist doch dass auch gut wir frühstücken
weiter aber es ist wahrscheinlich
schwierig zu lernen unglaublich
schwierig ich selbst bin da nicht der
ganz grosse experte für diese art von
kommunikation für diese validation das
ist ja während geht mit im gefühl dass
eine migration die methode wie man
wieder an den kern des menschen
überhaupt wo er ist man nicht immer das
gefühl auf und sie vermissen ihren mann
nicht aber wenn jemand nach hause will
dann bestätigen wir das gefühl das ist
wichtig dass man ein zuhause hat
man möchte gerne nach hause und das ist
eigentlich dann die art von
kommunikation ich glaube es ist die
einzige art von verbaler kommunikation
über die mir mit diesen menschen tun
können mit dieser schilderung haben sie
mindestens ein zweites großes
philosophisches thema aufgeworfen die
frage wie gehen wahrheit und würde
zusammen das glaube ich stelle ich mir
vor ist im pflegealltag täglich die
frage gilt das prinzip der absoluten
wahrheit offenbar nicht wenn man die
leute sind sonst sandown zurückholen
müsste aus einer zeit wo sie eben nicht
mehr sind aber wie halten sie das mit
der wahrheit wenn ihr zu einer zu ihnen
kommt und sagt du bist mein bruder dann
sage ich ihm dass ich nicht sein bruder
binden dann frage ich aber sind ihr
bruder ähnlich aus wie ich und dann
frage ich warum der herr wie hatte
geheißen dann kann ich ihnen ja so in
ein gespräch hineinbringen und ich
unterscheide sehr stark bei der wahrheit
und bei der liga
gibt es die individuelle geschichte die
oft als ohnmacht besteht dass man jemand
anlügt weil man sich nicht zu helfen
weiß
die andere geschichte ist dass wir heute
in einer welt leben in der es völlig
normal ist dass man menschen mit demenz
irgend etwas vormacht und dass man eben
dieser demenz der verbiete das wie das
jetzt entsteht mit den supermärkten und
so dass man einfach den menschen vor
macht sie leben irgendwo wo gar nicht
stecken sie leben ja alle in einem heim
und da bin ich schon jemand dafür kämpft
dass das nicht so ist ich das sagen sie
es geht gegen die wirte die wirte das
problem geht es gegen die würde der
patienten
es geht gegen das was wir menschen
untereinander ab gemacht haben
unabhängig von der diagnose sie ich habe
den anspruch dass man mich nicht belegt
ob ich eine demenz habe oder nicht
spielt ja keine rolle in unserer welt
würde ich ihnen das sofort bestätigen
und denke auch dass das ganz wichtig ist
habe ich mich aber gefragt als ich in
dem buch eben mehrfach gelesen habe dass
sie dieses prinzip ziemlich strikt
vertreten tobis in der anderen welt auch
gelten soll oder warum es dort gelten
soll und sie äußern sich ganz vehement
gegen eigentliche simulationen ich habe
aus einer reportage die einmal in 10 vor
10 gezeigt wurde
einen kleinen ausschnitt mitgebracht wo
man eine also nun zupackende überhaupt
nicht kaschierte simulation sieht die
menschen dort können in einem simulator
sozusagen eine zugs reise machen
es sieht aus wie ein ganz normaler
ausflug betagte menschen
doch dieser zug fährt nirgendwo hin
dieses erstklassigen bahnabteil ist ein
neues angebot für die bewohner des
alterszentrums bethlehem acker bern brig
mit eisenbahn originalton die zugfahrt
läuft in der endlosschleife das
historische und landschaft voller ich
habe die chance sogar die minibar kommt
vorbei was ist jetzt die täter dagegen
geht es dir das auszog satellit mit
süßen bewohner und bewohnerinnen das
ermögliche wo sie früher gemachte und
das was sie vor augen führen können
zugfahren mit virtuellen reisen positive
emotionen wecken
da hat er demenz fachmann michael
schmieder nun heftig den kopf
geschüttelt bei dieser einspielung aber
ich muss ihnen sagen ich extra poliere
jetzt mal von seinem jetzigen leben
ich mag flugsimulatoren ich entscheide
mich wenn ich nicht ein richtiges
flugzeug steigen kann gehe ich gerne in
einer simulation man simuliert ist es
bewegt sich es ist wie der zug simulator
und als ich das auch zum ersten mal habe
ich mir gesagt warum eigentlich nicht
wenn es den leuten freude macht wenn das
kriterium gilt wenn es den leuten freude
macht dann wird es dann sowieso weiter
warum also wenn ich unter diesem
kriterium alles erlauben
dann ist die frage auf wen und wie
können sich diese menschen noch
verlassen dass man das eine das andere
ist wenn sie gerne flugsimulatoren haben
ja dann machen sie das bewusst
entscheiden sich gehen ein flugsimulator
und wenn sie ein mit einer demenz
tatsächlich das noch lieben würden
würden wir sagen herr klapproth wir
haben für sie wieder den flugsimulator
hingestellt
also das ist eine andere geschichte
wenn man mit diesen menschen einen die
die spitze anders macht als frontal und
sagt wir schauen einen film über die
reise von bern nach kantons wallis und
das deklariert als film von bern ins
wallis dann ist das überhaupt nicht
angreifbar aber dass man menschen die
nicht erkennen dass sie in einer
virtuellen welt leben in einer
scheinwelt dass man diese menschen in
diesem glauben lässt
das hat der mensch an sich nicht
verdient
ich habe mir trotzdem überlegt ob das
wirklich auch gilt für die menschen von
denen sie sehr eindrücklich vorhin
gesagt haben die leben ohnehin ihm jetzt
also was ich vorher gesagt habe
ob das noch übereinstimmt mit dem was
ich nachher sagen wenn ich das recht sie
gibt es gar keine zeitachse mehr für die
menschen die ihm dauernd und jetzt leben
um sich daran etwas zu stören würde sie
das nicht stören wenn sie wüssten dass
sie keinen einfluss mehr hätten ob man
ihnen die wahrheit oder lüge für
unterbreitet ich stelle einfach die
freiheit gibt es die zurück also ein
absolut berechtigt ihre das müsste
zuerst daran tragen würde und hypo tätig
bin auch nicht sehen sie sagen
vielleicht nein weil ich mich frage ob
der begriff wahrheit
der heißt die dinge die in der realität
sind stimmen überein mit dem was wir
über sie sagen weil der begriff dort
wenn ich recht sehe gar nicht mehr
existieren kann
weil die dinge die wir über die realität
zu haben sind ja nicht mehr geordnet
wenn die die sprache der verstand die
logik weg ist sehe ich
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr recht was
wahrheit in diesem ewigen jetzt bedeuten
sollen oder sehe ich das total falsch
sie sehen das gibt total falsch die
frage kann man stellen
der ansatz den wir haben sagen mensch
die diagnose spielt keine rolle
über der in der diskussion ob wahrheit
oder lüge und wir glauben dass
verlässlichkeit auch beziehung nur
ehrlich ist wenn sie auf wahrheit
begründet ist und wenn ich menschen
etwas vormache dieser art dann kann da
keine ehrliche beziehung entstehen weil
ich als wissen ja entscheiden welche
wahrheit wird vorgesetzt
und das glaube ich das ist der das ist
nicht der punkt ob die das wahrnehmen
oder nicht was ist überhaupt nicht die
frage sondern will ich dass das sich
etwas bringen was übrigens das leben von
denen nicht einfacher macht höchstens
meines das ist nochmal das hat die
andere geschichte geht um die beziehung
ja es geht um beziehung und es geht
häufig darum dass man hilflos ist als
pflegender als betreuende und dann
solche geschichten braucht die
bushaltestelle nimmt das beispiel seiner
stelle im garten aufbaut eine
bushaltestelle wenn die leute sagen ich
will nach hause dann gesagt man warte
mal auf den jungs das finde ich jetzt
auch wieder
vielleicht ist es nicht sehr stringent
was ich hier jetzt theoretisieren aber
da habe ich auch einen wieder bildung zu
sagen da was sagt man wartete der bus
kommt und man weiß in der bus kommt
nicht mal virtuell der kommt einfach
überhaupt nicht da hat man nur sich
selbst entlasten da sagt wir fahren wir
fahren
ich war es aber ein bisschen wallis
kommt simuliert das war dies ja
natürlich es sind wahrscheinlich auch
zum teil spannende und schwierige
übergänge die frage der haustiere als
ich ihr heim kürzlich besuchen
städter ist ein hund nur schon in ihrem
büro und ich lese im buch auch wenn da
eine schöne geschichte eine warme die
die katze mitbringt und am schluss ist
die katze das maskottchen das nun bringt
- und die darin sagen sie es uns geht
den mehr bringt
die frau kam aus den usa direkt
vom flugzeug direkt in die soweit die
hat lange in den usa gelebt sie hat bei
uns in einer wohngruppe gelebt mit den
mit den mit anderen bewohnern und die
susi war dabei sie hat innerhalb vom
hals dann musste sie weil sie in der
wohngruppe nicht mehr richtig platziert
war hat sie einen anderen platz bei uns
bekommen und am schluss war sie in
dieser pflegeoase in dieser großraum
pflege kann man so sagen
und als sie gestorben ist war sie auf
der terrasse das bett schoben wir auf
die terrors es war der ehemann da es war
der sohn und die susi lag an den füßen
im bett von dieser frau und für mich
eine der eindrücklichsten momenten da
schon weit dass der hund da war und er
war ganz ruhig dieser mobster sonst ja
eigentlich sehr nervös durch die gegend
lief das heißt haustiere sind willkommen
bei ihnen ja stellt dann die frage die
in der mensch fachkreisen heißt
diskutiert wird ob sozusagen künstliche
haustiere berühmte pflege habe es gibt
also computer robben die simulieren
wiederum ein robben tier da würden sie
wie das ich schon sagen haustiere sehr
willkommen aber elektrische pseudo
haustiere kommen mir nicht ins haus
das ist so ja das ist auch da wieder
geht es darum was will ich mit dem und
es stimmt doch nicht wenn ich das tier
nehmen und sage ja parodie wie geht es
dir heute und das tier werden
elektronisch mit dem schwanz das kann es
doch nicht sein dass man menschen dem
aussetzt
das macht mich auch wütend da gibt es
aber andere fachleute das gibt heimat wo
man das praktiziert das sehen nicht alle
gleich aber da sind sie entschieden
dagegen für in holland gibt es neu kann
man die haustüre zu hause fotografieren
lassen und im pflegeheim die folie auf
die normale zimmer tiere machen
also es gibt alles es gibt heute dinge
zum aufspannen eigentlich kulisse wie im
fernsehen
und wenn man das vorbei hat dann packt
man wieder ein das kann doch nicht sein
dass man das tut weil die menschen
wollen eigentlich etwas anderes die
menschen wollen beziehen
die wollen nicht irgendwelche dinge
vorgesetzt bekommen aber sie wollen
beziehungen zu wollen die pfleger mit
den pflegenden in kontakt sein und es
gibt kein beweis dass es den menschen
die in diesen lügen
mit diesen lügen leben müssen dass es
denen pflegerisch oder betreuung später
geht die die ehrlich mit denen arbeit da
vertreten sie entschieden eine ganz
andere philosophie
zur frage würde und wahrheit gehört
wahrscheinlich auch dann das problem
aber vielleicht nicht einmal ein problem
oder die tatsache dass die menschen im
heim die patienten patientin ganz andere
normen haben dass die sie schreiben
gegen die zivilisation fällt weg und es
gibt fast romantisch zu lesende passagen
im buch plötzlich beginnt eine frau eine
neue dreiecksbeziehung im heim ist das
okay geht dass das geht das geht dann
wenn wir zwischen den menschen die das
dieser beziehung haben wenn wir sagen
können da haben wir keinen kognitiven
oder anderen macht unterschied
das ist etwas wo man sehr genau
hinschauen muss wenn jemand kognitiv
noch besser ist also mit seinen ganzen
leistungen und jemand überredet für zu
sexuellen handlungen dann muss man
schauen dass da die macht muss stimmen
das ist auch für viele menschen noch mal
eine möglichkeit beziehung zu haben das
ist ja etwas hervorragendes und wir
haben grundsätzlich ja freude daran wenn
wir merken menschen gehen händchenhalten
durch durch den garten oder durchs haus
also werden jetzt viele und ich
eingeschlossen vorher nicht vermutet
haben dass in dieser situation also neue
lebensabschnitt mit romantik und neuen
beziehungen entstehen hier natürlich die
gehen aber auch wieder ganz schnell weg
weil sie auch wieder vergessen werden
wir haben immer dass das thema das wir
sagen menschen die miteinander in
beziehung sind wir geben den die können
miteinander in ein zimmer gehen aber
beginnen geben denen nie den status von
einem gemeinsamen paar indem sie ein
zimmer kriegen weil es kann sein dass
morgen früh einer von den beiden das
schon
wer weiß was macht man mit der frage ob
der partner zu hause davon weiß davon
wissen muss wir informieren die partner
grundsätzlich wir fragen aber nicht ob
sie es erlauben oder nicht
wir glauben sexualität ist etwas was den
menschen eigen ist und wo wir als
partner oder ja wo wir nicht sagen
können ich will das oder ich will das
nicht
im übrigen ist das sei extrem schwierig
das zu verhindern das kennen wir als
eltern ja also von unseren eltern ja
auch aber wir informieren und fragen wie
möchten sie dass sie informiert sind und
dann kommt meistens schauen sie ich
möchte nicht mehr darüber wissen
aber ich möchte nicht wenn ich auf
besuch kommen dass meine frau
händchenhalten mit jemand anders da
setzt gibt es pflegende die damit wir
haben ich habe es gesehen als ich mein
bauch legen die durchs band wie ich sein
sehr liebevollen umgang mit den
patienten haben das gibt es gibt ja
natürlich weil wir unsere mitarbeiter
und mitarbeiterinnen ja aus völlig
unterschiedlichen lebens philosophischen
richtungen kommen und da versuchen wir
dann dass dieser menschen die damit mühe
haben in dem moment nicht damit
konfrontiert sind
es gibt die geschichte dass ein bewohner
dass wir eine berühren einer engagiert
haben vor vielen jahren war das und da
gab es mitarbeiterinnen die sagten das
entspricht nicht meiner moralität und da
hatten dann hat man sehr genau darauf
geschaut dass diese personen keinen
dienst hatten wenn die berühren würde
und wahrheit haben wir gesagt ist eine
philosophische dimension dieser wahltag
dauernd im blick behalten müssen und
dann vermutlich wird es nochmal viel
existenzieller indem sie eine
philosophische wenn es dann um die frage
geht wie kann man in würde sterben
dazu müssen wir vielleicht auch sagen
eine eigenheit ihres konzepts ist auch
es gibt eigentlich drei stationen auf
dem weg den die leute bei ihnen gehen
drei stationen
wohngruppe haben sie gesagt fängt das an
solange das geht dann im eigentlichen
heim klassische betreuung für anleihen
der da vorbeikommt und dann die oase
letzten kapitel ist man in der oase was
ist die oase
also man ist nie nicht grundsätzlich im
letzten kapitel in der oase es wird bei
uns in allen bereichen gestorben
es ist nicht so dass jemand der in die
wohngruppe eintritt dass durchläuft die
oase ist ein ort ich nenne so ganz
salopp wenn man sagt großraum pflege
sind acht bewohner in diesem raum die
alle miteinander irgendwie in kontakt
sind weil es gibt keine zwischenwände
der ansatz der gedanke der dahinter
steht ist folgender menschen den zwei
quadratmeter bit den der lebensraum ist
begrenzt auf diese zwei quadratmeter mit
denen müssen wir ja kommunikativ noch
irgendetwas anderes anbieten als nur
dieses zimmer ein noch zimmer in dem ein
bett steht die vereinsamen völlig und
wenn wir daran denken dass wir ja
tausende immer in der gruppe gelebt
haben wir menschen sind ja nicht
einzelne lebewesen dann glauben wir
heute dass in diesem schwersten und
helle letzten stadium einer demenz
dieses bedürfnis nach gemeinschaft
wieder sehr stark in den vordergrund
rückt und nicht das bedürfnis nach
individualität die gibt es ist sehr
individuell aber es ist nicht einsam
das glaube ich das ist der unterschied
und man muss sich das vorstellen wenn
nur jemand am bett vorbeiläuft und sagt
guten tag herr schmid dann schon kann
ich kommunizieren wenn nur jemand wenn
ich rufe wenn ich so viele menschen rufe
nach ihrem mut und es kommt irgendwo
antwort herr schmiede ich habe sie
gehört dann halt doch das schon wieder
eine kommunikative komponente und ich
bin immer in die vororte als bewohner
ich bin immer teil von einem ganzen
system
und das ist das was wir wollen wir
wollen dass der mensch nicht vereinsamt
und heute würde ich sagen die die
menschen leben wahrscheinlich länger in
den oasen wie wie sie leben würden in
kleineren zimmern hat es fälle gegeben
wo sie gespürt haben
hier ist ein mensch der möchte doch
allein sein
sie werden staunen dass sie das spüren
sie erst mal spüren cis aber das kommt
äußerst selten vor
der mensch ist nicht gerne alleine das
widerspricht allem was wir heute leben
wie wir heute diesen individualismus den
wir heute predigen der mensch in die
verkrampftheit in dieser jetzt diesem
vergessen mit diesen ganzen niederen
kognitiven leistungen der mensch werden
nicht alleine sein der mensch will immer
betreuung das ist die große lehre aus
dieser krankheit dieses jahr aber mit
der krankheit nichts zu tun
der mensch will immer mit jemandem
kontakt seien plötzlich bei der lektüre
des buches ging mir durch den kopf diese
krankheit die mir auch noch mehr angst
gemacht hatte er bevor ich mich
überhaupt damit befasst hatte hat
vielleicht die andere seite dass der
abschied dann der tod mit weniger angst
daherkommt kann man das so sagen das
können wahrscheinlich kann man das so
sagen das die menschen spüren dass es zu
ende geht das bin ich überzeugt aber ich
glaube ja da ist weniger angst da es ist
oftmals auch sehr friedvoll und sehr
friedlich und auch da es gibt menschen
die wollen alleine sterben die warten
bis die angehörigen kaffee trinken gehen
und es gibt angehörige die warten bis
unbedingt die tochter aus der usa noch
kommt dann oder in früheren phasen lese
ich und weiß man ja auch aus anderen
berichten wenn der schock da kommt daher
kommt für einen menschen du hast
demenz da gibt es menschen die sagen so
will ich nicht enden lieber gehe ich in
den freitod gunter sachs ist ein
berühmtes beispiel hat die diagnose
nicht war richtig aber er sagt so und
viele denken wahrscheinlich so will ich
nicht sterben und treffen vor kehren
damit das nicht passiert das ist auch in
einem film in einem hollywoodfilm aber
sehr schön amerikanisch französischen
film drama series julian [ __ ] die
berühmte darstellerin hat den oscar für
die eindrückliche darstellerische
leistung gewonnen und in diesem film
sieht man wie sie beginnt vorkehren für
den freitod zu treffen der film erzählt
die geschichte einer erfolgreichen frau
einer professorin einer intellektuellen
die langsam merkt das sind lücken in
meinem denken ausfälle
orientierungsschwierigkeiten beim joggen
sogar auf dem eigenen campus den sie wie
die westentasche kennen sollte weil sie
plötzlich nicht mehr recht wo sie ist
und trifft einen folgenreichen plan für
die zukunft
[Musik]
sie hat sich ein video vorbereitet weil
sie weiß im späteren zustand wird sie
sich in computer und und erzählt sich
selbst im video anleitungen zum teil ist
das jetzt völlig hollywood oder gibt es
was ich glaube es gibt so viele menschen
wie es gibt mit der diagnose überlegt
man will ich weiter leben und wie lange
will ich weiterleben
das ist die entscheidende zeit dann da
ob man einen weg finden kann und das ist
dann die aufgabe von vielen fachleuten
die sich da auch darum kümmern dass man
weiß heute die zeit nach der diagnose
das ist eigentlich die schwierigste zeit
und dass leute sich vorsehen was sie
dann tun werden
das kennen wir das kennen wir von vielen
menschen aber niemand tut niemand tut
die niemand alleine selbst alleine jetzt
mit angehörigen ist das noch mal etwas
neueres aber niemand tut das zum schluss
selbständig weil er weiß nicht mehr was
er wollte die menschen versuchen ja dann
diesem zeitpunkt möglichst lange
hinauszuzögern
und irgendwann ist es zu spät und dann
können wir nicht mehr und dann kommt
auch eine andere qualität von leben dazu
weil es dann nicht mehr so sorgenvoll
ist und heute es sind wenige menschen
mit demenz die sich so zitieren
es gibt den beeindruckenden fall in
ihrem buch eines schweizer autors und
schriftsteller edward s der mit seiner
frau zusammen zu beginn seiner krankheit
verabredungen trifft das er dann mit
exit in den freitod gehen kann
wie lief das dann ab der fall hat ja
grundsätzlich mal wählen auf geworfen
weil ja auch die ehefrau dass er
offensiv vertraut sie beschreibt er das
auch in den buchen sie beschreibt hat
das auch in einer fernsehsendung dann so
gesagt
am schluss hat er gesagt kommt wir war
war der termin fest gestanden und dann
hat sie gesagt hat er gesagt wir warten
noch eine woche kommen
wir warten nur einer woche das ist als
ich das gelesen habe dass das nimmt
einem das nimmt der hand hätte den plan
und jetzt sagt er das ist doch eine eine
eine dramatische situation und dann
verkündet die ehefrau jetzt haben wir 50
jahre oder vor unter lang zusammengelebt
jetzt kommt jetzt doch auf dieser woche
nicht mehr an
jetzt machen wir das und das ist der
entscheidende satz warum ich heute noch
der meinung bin das war nicht eine
autonome entscheid aber es ist schwierig
zu sagen wenn ich weiß ich werde an
einem punkt später nicht mehr autonom
sein ich mache jetzt den autonomen
entscheid für dann das liegt in der
freiheit des individuums würde sie sagen
es ist ein kategorien fehler man sollte
das nicht tun
wie wollen sie etwas entscheiden für
etwas was sie nachher gar nicht mehr
wissen dass sie das entschieden haben
auch ich muss oft für später entscheiden
und wenn es gibt ja auch dieses beispiel
dass jemand schreibt ich will nicht dass
man mir essen ein gibt wenn ich nicht
mehr selber essen kommen ja jetzt sitzen
sie da mit schwerer demenz und essen
begeistert wenn man ihnen den löffel
hinhält so nicht jetzt den pflegenden
sorgen her glaubt willi hat gewünscht
dass man nicht nichts mehr essen gibt
aber eigentlich wünscht er dass jetzt
die das ist nicht immer was man vorher
aufgeschrieben hat ist nicht immer
finden für das was jetzt ist für viele
geht das über in eine phase wo die angst
weg ist
das ist vielleicht eben die die
sonnenseite eine sehr düstere situation
und haben sie mir erzählt beim besuch in
einem ist auch ja nicht so dass alles
weg ist sondern auch die kunst ist
irgendwie noch da und sie haben etwas
mitgebracht
sie versuchen mit kunst eigentlich auch
diesen übergang dann den den endgültigen
abschied er irgendwie zu gestalten
spürbaren zu machen was an
mitgekommen kunst ist ja ein sehr
relativer begriff
wir machen mit jedem bewohner der zu uns
kommt wer eine frau die das auch mit
liebe sehr viel liebe macht machen wir
zwei tonfiguren und in dem moment wenn
es der bewohner und diese tonfigur
herstellt schreibt sie auch noch auf was
dieser menschen dem augenblick sagt und
wenn diese person gestorben ist treffen
wir immer die angehörigen noch zu einem
schluss gespräch und dann überreichen
wir ihnen eine dieser figuren und die
andere figur die bringen wir bei uns in
den raum der stille war sie an den
figuren sehen sie haben den letzten
bleibenden eindruck und das finde ich
jemand dieser große moment wenn wir das
überreichen können
und dann hat der rolf p am 16
zwölfter hat er die figur gemacht und
hat gesagt ich bin ein alter mann
manchmal habe ich tiefste angst aber ich
will hier bleiben bis ich mich auf
gelöst habe und wenn sie das den
angehörigen mitgeben können das ist doch
ein wunderbares geschenk noch in als ja
ein wunderbares abschiedsgeschenk kunst
spielt den staub des alltags von der
seele hat wie das so gesagt und sie
hatten mich darauf hingewiesen dass eine
andere art von kunst auch fast jeden tag
den garten der sonnweid zitiert erwischt
nämlich mit diesem reisigbesen täglich
und macht ihm ein kunstwerk dabei
erwischt die wege und macht muss da
hinein und wir haben das aufgegriffen
und haben heute unter dem begriff
ungekünstelt punkt ch einer homepage
gemacht indem wir in der wir solche
kunstwerke das ist die nec einer der
nächsten möglichkeiten in der wir solche
kunstwerke zeigen wollen also etwas geht
es uns einfach verloren
und jeden morgen wischt der hauswart ist
wieder weg ja also auch fast ein
philosophisches
zeichen wie mars leben gestaltet was
davon bleibt das nicht bleibt aber
bedanke mich herzlich war sehr
eindrücklich mit ihnen über diese fragen
zu reden herzlichen dank
am karfreitag reden wir dann hier in der
sternstunde mit der weltbekannten
psychologin susan pinker die wand wer
den kontakt zu den mitmenschen vielmehr
über das internet statt von auch zu
hause pflegt erlebt weniger glücklich
und weniger lang als menschen mit viel
direktkontakte einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]